today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
okay guys we have to start today with
a very real very sobering conversation
i wish we didn't have to have this
conversation but i'm not going to blow
smoke up down in out of anywhere
um maybe we can get something positive
out of it and i don't say that in a sort
of
coy or you know kind of bs way a
teachable moment like maybe we can
actually get something out of this
because it's increasingly clear that
republicans if they choose to if they
decide
that the political risks are reasonable
are going to have the votes to move
forward
with a replacement of ruth bader
ginsburg on the supreme court
yes they are hypocrites yes they're
completely ignoring the guidelines
they claimed were necessary in 2016
to deny barack obama a supreme court
pick
to replace the late justice antonin
scalia with merrick garland
but the reality is we have to deal with
reality that democrats right now
don't have a path to stopping donald
trump
from replacing ruth bader ginsburg it
will be up to republicans
remember that the numbers are um
republicans have 53 of the 100 senate
seats
in order to deny them the 51 or it's
really
50 votes that they have to be denied
because even in a 50 50 vote mike pence
gets to tiebreak and you know how that
will go
um we need to find four republicans who
will refuse to move forward with a
confirmation we heard from lisa
murkowski from alaska
she is one such republican who has said
at least
not before the election during the lame
duck who knows
we then heard from susan collins from
maine
another republican senator who says not
before the election
no but bear in mind even
if we wait it out until november 3rd and
joe biden wins
these same two republicans lisa
murkowski and susan collins
may well be willing to push someone
through during a lame duck period
and in any case two isn't going to be
enough to stop it
uh donald tru uh mitt romney rather is
someone that
people have been looking towards maybe
mitt romney could be a third republican
as of right now mitt romney has said
uh it looks like he's going to be okay
moving forward and
even if mitt romney could be added as
number three to the list you need a
fourth
so the reality today is
we have to contend with this
situation there is a very real practical
lesson here
and it's a lesson to all of those people
you remember them i remember them some
of them even have youtube channels
who in 2016 were saying trump and
hillary
are two sides of the same coin
if it's trump or hillary i don't care
they're both corporatist centrists and
it really doesn't matter which one is
elected for the next four years or eight
years
and i mentioned the supreme court in
2015 and 2016 and
you know some of these clowns some of
them said supreme court
it's not like hillary's going to pick
any real left wingers to the court
well donald trump stole one from obama
with neil gorsuch
and then he got brett kavanaugh two
ludicrous ideologues the likes of which
hillary clinton
never would have even considered putting
on the court
and now donald trump is on the verge of
ingraining the most conservative supreme
court in a long time
by replacing ruth bader ginsburg with a
straight-up
handmaid's tale right-wing cultist
who i will be talking about later this
is not
i told you so stuff this is a learning
experience
this is learning from mistakes if we can
learn from it now if we can't
then we arguably deserve what's coming
and what's coming could be very very bad
the supreme court did matter the people
who wrote it off
in 2016 and the people who are writing
it off right now
in 2020 they were wrong they are wrong
period abortion rights are now going to
be in question
partially because there were people in
2016 who mistakenly thought
trump or hillary is going to lead to the
same results this is not about
shaming people this is not about shame
this is about hey guys
some of us questioned the importance of
the difference between trump and hillary
in 2016 not me but some of us did
this is about understanding that there
are things we can control and things we
can't control
in 2016 we could control our votes in
the primaries
once hillary was the nominee we couldn't
change that
but we could then control whether we
voted in november of 2016
and who we voted for and some people
made the decision not to vote
some people who supported candidates
other than hillary during the primary
made the decision not to vote or to vote
for trump or to write somebody in or
whatever
and of course a whole bunch of other
things happened as well which affected
the results but it was ultimately 77
000 votes in three key states and now
donald trump is going to get his third
supreme court pick
in one term possibly with more coming if
he gets a second term
they were wrong then many of them acted
like spoiled
children then they're not the only thing
to blame
of course but they were wrong the whole
both sides are the same ideology
is an easy way for
lazy people or intellectually uncurious
people
to feel as though they're above it all
i've sometimes used the term enlightened
centrist
there's also these folks on the left and
on the right it's not just centrists
and it has been a disaster so okay
it's almost october what can we control
now
we can control whether we vote in this
election
we can control whether donald trump gets
four more years
and potentially one or even two
more supreme court picks and as a result
gets to set the country on what will
potentially be
one of its darkest periods certainly of
the 21st century but probably for
for longer and if you need any further
words of warning
let's discuss next who donald trump is
considering
to replace ruth bader ginsburg
it's dystopian let's discuss it
everybody needs to buckle up
because things are about to get
absolutely insane as donald trump is set
to nominate
one of a few dystopian handmaid's tale
type
ideologues cultists literal cultists
to the supreme court to replace ruth
bader ginsburg
donald trump has said he will be making
the announcement saturday
5 p.m eastern from the white house
one of the people donald trump is
reportedly considering
who is again reports are that she is the
front runner
is judge amy coney barrett
who is against roe v wade against
abortion
connected to the right-wing federalist
society
part of a pseudo-religious cult and
has a long list of absolutely disturbing
beliefs which we are going to discuss
now why is amy coney barrett a known
entity
she's a known entity because uh back in
2017
under trump she was confirmed to the
seventh circuit court of appeals
and so we learned a lot about her in
2017. to start with
she is a strict constructionist who has
criticized roe v wade many times and
said that
the court is likely to chip away at
abortion protections on the friday show
i'll talk more about
what that could actually look like
barrett and her husband are members of a
group
called people of praise this is a cult
i got emails from viewers whose families
were previously involved with people of
praise
it is a pseudo-religious pseudo church
cult it's not exactly a church
it's a christian parachurch organization
and it is reminiscent of gilead
in margaret atwood's handmaid's tale if
you read about people of praise you will
see that for example the highest office
a woman can hold
in a people of praise community is now
called woman leader
it used to be called handmade i i'm not
exaggerating
this is literally trump going in the
direct
direction of margaret atwood's gilead
i'm not making it up as i mentioned
barrett used to be a member of the
federalist society that's the group
that actually was bankrolling the
nomination of brett kavanaugh to the
court
amy coney barrett is eager to
get rid of obamacare barrett reportedly
spoke to students well no she did speak
to students at notre dame
and reportedly said that a legal career
is merely a means to an
end and that the end wait for it is
building
the kingdom of god a religious
cultist who believes legal careers are
meant to serve
god is potentially going to be nominated
to the supreme court
to replace ruth bader ginsburg
that is what we are up against here 77
000 votes in three states got us here
today
now barrett is only a few of what
are considered to be the front runners
so we could go into barrett's
court decisions which are disturbing but
she may not actually be the nominee so
we'll wait on that we'll wait and see
who actually is selected on saturday the
time will come for that
so we are slowly but surely moving more
and more towards a status quo
that resembles that of dystopian fiction
including that described by margaret
atwood
in a handmaid's tale and the sequel the
testaments which i also
recommend i read it a couple months ago
and this is where we are we have an
election
in under six weeks to go from ruth bader
ginsburg to this lunacy is beyond
devastating gilead is a sort of
republican religious right-winger wet
dream
and it is what donald trump is creating
a sort of male-dominated conservative
society
suppression of minority rights
prevalence of
certain people seen more as though
they are less than human and more like
property
than others not literal slavery of
course the suppression of women's rights
it's all happening margaret atwood
created the story
to serve as a warning and the republican
party
under donald trump is using it almost
like a blueprint
republicans are trying to create that
religious body within government within
the supreme court giving them
veto power over culture and society it's
not just
this is this is no longer like left
versus right it's far
deeper than that it's ideological it's
dystopian it's a nightmare
and we can't control everything as i
said
but we can still control whether we all
get out and vote
45 of eligible adults didn't
vote in 2016. non-voters
won so to speak or if non-voting was a
candidate non-voting would have won
in something like 85 or 90 percent of
the states
in 2016. let's not forget that
we we have agency here we can take
action
but it looks like it's going to get very
very ugly very very quickly
let me know your thoughts about the
direction of all of this i'm on twitter
at d pacman the david pakman show at
[Music]
davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that this is a program mostly
funded
by memberships memberships are quick
easy
cheap and come with the daily bonus show
an
extra show just for our members
grab a membership in under a minute or
take longer i mean listen if you want to
spend five minutes on it by all means
but you only need about 45 seconds at
joinpackman.com
it is time for hatred mail quick
reminder what is hatred mail anyway
because we don't care about liberal
cucks
so much that we spend our time writing
to them
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate david pakman
because america and because
freedom yeah so hatred mail is i get a
lot of hate mail
and some of it is interpretively read
by a professional voice-over artist
there is a lot of
meat and really ugly stuff in this
week's hatred mail
let's take a listen david pakman hating
on guns
oh jewish confirmed
yep predictable david i could only get
through a moment of your socialist
drivel weird because david doesn't
really
look jewish i am oh
but listen to him for a second and you
know
david how do you explain jewish people's
success
yeah don't look jewish continues to be
an interesting one that we we've talked
about that
um and in fact there's there's actually
a lot of interesting
sociological stuff about this idea of
looking
jewish or looking this that or the other
thing
let's not get into that because that
gets pretty ugly but still with the
socialist stuff
at this point it's a very interesting
thing
i think i get as much criticism
from the audience from people who attack
me wrongly
for being a socialist or a communist as
i do from people who are mad
that i'm not a socialist or a communist
it's a very interesting thing as many of
you know
i'm a social democrat in the northern
european tradition
the this is a form of capitalism it's
well regulated capitalism
using redistributive mechanisms
to ensure that no one's standard of
living
is is unnecessarily low and um
there are people on the right who don't
care and
insist that i am a socialist or a
communist and then there are people on
the left who are mad
that i'm not actually a socialist or a
communist you can't please everybody and
lately it seems like you almost can't
please anybody
but what you can do to fight patriotism
in your community is to use the coupon
code
hatred 40 when you sign up for a
membership you go to joinpakman.com
you will be presented with a coupon code
field you type in hatred 40
h-a-t-r-i-o-t 4-0
and you'll save 40 percent okay we do
have some important breaking news today
about the hopefully forthcoming
coronavirus vaccine
as many of you know donald trump has put
many political eggs
in the basket of being able to announce
a coronavirus vaccine before election
day
and donald trump has for a while now
been talking about could be mid-october
could be even sooner
and remember that this was never going
to be a standard fda approval for the
vaccine the hope was what trump was
counting on
was an emergency use authorization from
the fda now
at its core from the starting point
an eua is already not as rigorous of a
process
as a full approval for a vaccine but
even the possibility of the emergency
use authorization
now is significantly less likely because
the fda announced just hours ago
that it's going to be tightening up the
authorization standards for vaccine
emergency use making it very
unlikely that donald trump is going to
get this announcement before election
day now this matters for two reasons
first of all this matters from a public
health standpoint
we need a vaccine and it's going to be
longer than some hoped for the eu a
now the counterpoint is we all
knew that trump wanted to announce the
eua
even though the vaccine doses were never
really going to be available widely in
2020
so this may not really change when the
average person will get the vaccine
it's merely going to change donald trump
getting to announce it before the
election
and that's why there's a big political
implication here
donald trump was counting on being
buoyed
in the polls by being able to say we got
a vaccine
now we knew all along that even if he
got the emergency
authorization in the next few weeks
before the election
it was going to be a while before
anybody could really get the vaccine any
significant number
a number of people but incredibly this
may be even more
self-inflicted damage by donald trump
because
part of the reason why the fda is now
saying
we're going to make it tougher stricter
we're going to boost transparency
part of the reason they are doing this
is because so many people have expressed
concern
that donald trump has politicized the
vaccine
and people are rightly skeptical about
what it would really mean for an early
eua from the fda
if the fda is merely under the thumb of
donald trump the fda
is going to put in place a number of new
requirements
it is going to put in place the
requirement of following participants in
these late stage
clinical trials for a median of at least
two months
starting after the second dose of the
vaccine
the predominant number of vaccines being
tested are two doses typically separated
by about 30 days per the news
times as a sign that the vaccine works
the agency also is planning to look more
closely
at people with severe cases of
coronavirus
and looking at specifically
people in the placebo groups who got
coronavirus and doing a lot
more than what some were hoping would be
done if you were hoping for an early
approval
this is going to take time and the
agency uh previously said that any
vaccine would have to be at least 50
percent more effective than a placebo
so now we're hearing from all sorts of
experts including paul offit who directs
the vaccine education center at
children's hospital of philadelphia he
says
quote it's hard to imagine how an
emergency use authorization
could possibly occur before december
moderna has now said they are unlikely
to have the required data
by the end of october astrazeneca
has had to stop their trial as they're
looking into this
serious neurological problem that
happened to a participant in that trial
um pfizer had a vaccine which
conceivably could have been the one
that maybe in october could have gotten
an emergency use authorization but based
on the new restrictions
that is likely to be postponed now
there's another
sort of parallel story to this which is
that a whole bunch of the country
still says they're not going to get a
coronavirus vaccine they will not seek
it out
and that is more trump people than biden
people people who
thanks in part to donald trump's
administration still aren't taking
coronavirus seriously
there's new data from the pew research
center which reports that the percentage
of americans who say
they would get the vaccine if it were
available today
has dropped to just about 50
back in may in that same study
72 percent of respondents said i'd get
the vaccine
now just over 50 percent of respondents
say they would get the vaccine so
consider the insanity
of this country on the one hand trump
has been banking on announcing a vaccine
that he had no role in developing to try
to get himself reelected
on the other hand it's his followers who
disproportionately
don't plan to get the vaccine anyway
raising the question of well
would the vaccine announcement even
really helped trump
that much i don't know the answer it's
stunning stuff
and it doesn't seem as though donald
trump is going to get that announcement
now one other issue to talk about
this is a broader issue and we're
looking into bringing an expert on to
ask them about it
should vaccines ever
be authorized via an emergency use
authorization
anyway there are critics who say euas
are not for vaccines okay you do you get
early data that remdesseviere is working
you do an emergency use authorization
with with you know
caveats and restrictions you get early
data that dexamethasone
is reducing mortality in serious
coronavirus patients
you do an emergency use authorization
for a vaccine you don't do it
say some critics now there are others
who say
you you do want to keep an eua for a
vaccine on the table
when you have thousands of people a week
dying
if you get an efficacy signal that is
good enough and what
good enough means of course needs to be
delineated more specifically
you you consider an eua then
you need to figure out do any of the
vaccines that we actually have available
warrant an eua and that's a more
specific question to be answered
reasonable people can disagree about
that from a political standpoint
it does not appear that donald trump is
going to get it we're going to have more
on vaccination on the david pakman show
instagram
that's david pakman show on instagram
make sure you're following us there the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous bonus show as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right we're welcoming back uh sort
of an old friend to the show i guess
although sometimes he throws me off the
show
jessie lee peterson is joining us he is
host of the jesse lee peterson show
he's host of the fallen state which i
visited the studio
when i was in los angeles uh and jesse
are you
are you uh are you a pastor as well do i
recall that correctly are you a
christian pastor
i am yes you are and what what
denomination
non-denominational christian okay and i
remember that your studio in la people
may find this interesting
is it also some kind of christian
counseling center
do i remember that correctly where you
counsel young men
yeah but uh not in the studio we have i
have my offices
upstairs and so we we counsel in
in-house and
by skype or telephone or by phone
whichever season for the folks
that's fascinating and so now you're
you're not like a therapist right you're
not a social worker or a psychologist or
anything like that
no just a counselor okay and that that's
in california that's an unregulated
credential right anybody can use that
term
well you have to you have to be a
minister or pastor or something like
that
and you can do counseling under the head
in them of your ministry
wow and that insurance doesn't cover
that right it does
it does in california you can go to a
counselor who's just a minister and it's
considered a medical visit
100 as a matter of fact it's better that
you come to me than the people with the
degrees
well that's an opinion that's an opinion
but i'm concerned with the legal piece
if you notice and by the way we are
friends david even though i had to
throw you off one day we still sometimes
i throw my friends off okay
but uh it's better that you come to me
than a person with a degree because
if you notice the educated people are
dumb they have no sense
i've not noticed that i've not noticed
that and they end up
giving the people after they run after
them just before the people run out of
money
they give them medication because the
therapists
uh the trained therapists and counselors
psychologists and psychiatrists have no
common sense
a lot of the people you just mentioned a
lot of the people you just mentioned
can't even prescribe medication so
psychologists don't prescribe neither do
social workers so what you're saying
you know it's not true right well what
i'm saying is that
people with degrees of dummies they have
no common sense they're just okay this
is what someone told them
i gotcha all right now now i understand
because the first thing you said is
literally
impossible because they can't prescribe
but it's glad you hear that
you're glad to hear that good and you
can't prescribe you're not prescribing
anything i'm guessing no
no no okay good um so listen jesse we're
on the precipice here of an election
and the reason i wanted to talk to you
is
to figure out on because you're such a
master of
policy you know economics and
trade and all of these things i wanted
to figure out where you are
on trump and policy so let just to begin
with i mean you you approve of the job
the president is doing right
he's done an amazing job thus far in
spite of the children of the lie
yeah and the children of the line the
liberal media the democratic party the
never trumpers
the right of republicans the black race
hustlers and the radical homosexuals
they have been against him and our
enemies
overseas as well but in spite of that
he's done an amazing job so four more
years of the great white hope
yeah and when you talk about the job
that trump has done
just to pick something to really dig
into and make this a
you know i want to take the interview
seriously and you know hopefully it
won't devolve the way some of the prior
interviews have
let's take economics and taxation for
example
do you like the trump tax plan and if so
what do you like about it well that's
why i like the fact that he is
cut back on taxes and giving more money
to the workers
rather than taking it i like the fact
that he
um has made it easier for small
businesses to get going
even though we have a chinese virus
situation right now so the economy uh
has stopped a little bit
but it's starting to come back and dude
what's the
regulations but let's pick something
let's pick one thing
what has trump done to make it easier
for
businesses to get going by cutting back
on so many rules and regulations that
the democrat had established
like what what's an example of such a
such a rule i don't have anything
in mind right now yeah but a lot of the
rules of regulation that was preventing
uh uh small businesses from starting
yeah have been taken away by the great
white hope what would be but so give me
just i don't i know that there's dozens
and dozens but what's one such rule
that was taken away that now makes it
easier to start a business
nothing come to mind right now it is
there anything that you can remember
even seeing at any time nothing come to
mind
nothing wow that's amazing amazing
yeah uh okay all right so let's stick
with economics just for a moment
what do you think the top marginal tax
rate should be for for top earners
good question man i don't know i haven't
thought about it at this point
is it too high or too low currently if
it went no
i'm sorry wouldn't you say your phone
went out for a minute what'd you say
i said do you think the current top
marginal tax rate is too high or too low
i'm not sure at this time david you're
not sure so how do you know
that trump's tax plan is good if you
don't even know what tax rates are and
how he changed them
well because i have not been focusing on
that lately i have more important things
to think about and
do that has not been one of my primary
focus at this point all right well let's
take a different topic then
uh donald trump made a huge deal during
the campaign
in 2016 and now about trade
trade with china trade with mexico
and canada do you believe that donald
trump
has fulfilled his campaign promises on
trade or do you believe he has fallen
short he has not fallen short but he has
not completed them at this time that's
why we have to one of the reasons but
not the only that we have to do four
more years
yeah so he can finalize the trade deals
that he
is working on what would you like to see
him do on
trade that he's not yet done to make
sure that america
is being treated fairly in trade deals
and that we're not giving away or being
used
as we have been in the past in those
ways
interesting so donald trump yesterday at
his rally
said that he fixed china that now china
has to treat us fairly because he fixed
it and he says that he fixed canada and
mexico with usmca
so they're now treating us fairly so
who's left that's not treating us fairly
on trade
did he mention that yesterday i didn't
hear that at all it was either yesterday
or i mean the rallies are blending
together maybe it was the day before did
he say who
who was left that he had to deal with no
i'm asking you who do you think is still
treating us against
the call the white house sportsman yeah
sports person and they can answer those
questions for you i have no idea
well but i guess what i'm trying to
understand jesse is
government so you're asking me the wrong
questions right but so
you you asserted that you like a lot of
what trump accomplished on trade right
but believe
that but hold on jesse hold on jesse
though no hold on jesse hold on i'm
asking about david you have to
call the white house you're gonna have
plenty of time to answer let me just get
the question out
you asserted that you like some of what
he did on trade
but you want to see him do more i'm
saying what more should he do
i have no idea david but he knows so you
should call
them and ask them you're asking me the
wrong questions okay that's that's
interesting because
it sounds like you don't really know
what's going on
not totally no no okay that area i'm not
concerned about that either
i'm gl well but you mentioned it as
something you liked so it must concern
you
what the president is doing and hasn't
done this more and bringing jobs back
as far as some of the changes he's done
but for more information you should
contact them
but you don't think you should be in and
you're waiting for your time i just tell
you you should contact them don't you
understand are you it's hard to
understand
no it's coming it's actually coming
through clearer than that
if you want to continue you need to move
on because you're asking the wrong
person
so you're a very strong advocate of the
president and you very
powerfully you powerfully say on your
program people should vote for him
but you seem unable to articulate what
he's actually done
by those things you just asked i have no
idea i'm not even concerned okay
how would you tackle climate change
jesse no such thing
okay and and elaborate on that
it's a made-up lie by the liberal
democrats in order to
get more money in power and control the
people climate change is fake
you know in some countries
uh climate change is much less
politicized in other words you might
have scientists who are
conservative and scientists who are
liberal
and they all agree about it why do you
think in other countries
even the conservative scientists accept
the science on climate
i have no idea but in america climate
change is fake
in them in america maybe in those maybe
in those
i don't know for sure but maybe in those
other countries they're controlling the
people
because of people weak minded and they
allow themselves to be controlled by
lies
interesting and that's happening that's
happening in other countries
well maybe i don't know for sure what's
going on in other countries but in my
country
is climate change is fake are you um
you're you're of course in coastal
california which is a place
that if the sea level continues to rise
could have flooding problems
we've also seen a number of prominent
conservatives abandon california for
more
politically conservative parts of the
country is that something you're
thinking about
about abandoning california yeah because
it's so liberal
not at this time it i mean at one time
for the first time in all my
i've been here since 1968 yeah it did
cross my mind but i'm not ready to pack
up and run at this time
i believe that america uh california
will come back to become a
conservative state because the democrats
have done a good job
in screwing it up when it comes to
illegal aliens
homelessness not a lot down from the
so-called chinese virus
the fires the high taxes uh
and even with all of that jesse you
still prefer it to other conservative
parts of the country after decades
that's interesting
i i because i love california i like the
the well it used to be beauty beautiful
at one time
yep i like the opportunities in
california and just an amazing state
we just need to get the democrats out
and replace it with conservative
republicans
right and you think you'll like it even
more if republicans take over california
if they're conservatives and not rhinos
i believe that we can put it back to
a normal state of being prior to the
democrats completely taking over
what's something really specific in
terms of the law
that you'd like to see california do
differently it could be anything it
could be on
you know guns it could be on economic
paul like what would you like to see
changed in california from a legal
standpoint well number one i would like
to see
the uh borders closed shut down
completely so the air leakings cannot
come in
i would like to see laws that says we
will not and cannot and shall not pay
for
so-called health care for illegal aliens
or anyone who is
unwilling to work for themselves i would
love to see lower taxes for
uh uh home buyers land buyers and people
like that
um the restriction as far as
the second amendment right they need to
take their hands off our second
amendment we have the right to buy
bullets
wow to own whatever gun we want and has
as
many as we want i will change some of
those rules
um i uh we're going to go to a break on
the podcast but my full conversation
with with jessie lee peterson will of
course be published to our youtube
channel
in full no edits jesse you know we never
edit anything you say
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about
them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
donald trump held another rally
yesterday this time it was in moon
township pennsylvania which is where i
guess the pittsburgh airport is
trump arriving in every state and
basically
telling them all the same thing now your
state had its best year
ever last year then the china virus came
in as he calls it but next year's going
to be the best again it's going to be
the best year ever next year
trump seemed sort of particularly wound
up yesterday maybe he was reacting to
early news that the vaccine emergency
use authorization he had been hoping for
for october is not going to happen as we
discussed earlier in the program
could have been anything you never know
could have seen something on the plane
on the way in that
enraged him let's look at some
outrageous moments
i know that lots of these rallies start
to blend together
but we are under six weeks from the
election and people are voting now
early voting absentee voting i don't
want any of this behavior to be
normalized
so we're going to keep talking about it
maybe the strangest moment of the entire
event
was donald trump lamenting that he
doesn't have any friends anymore
check this out the crowd sort of doesn't
know what to make of it
i could call up every guy they call me
up and they say sir
how are you sir mr president sir i have
frenzy
i don't have too many friends up because
i used to be comfortable you
have to be comfortable with people right
and i have friends i have one friend
richard i talk about them all the time
but they're
multiply this times 100 people and
richard used to call me up five six
years ago hey let's have dinner
all right where do you want to go i
don't know go to some crazy restaurant
today the restaurants are all closed in
new york they don't want to open them
they want to make them do badly until
november but don't worry they're opening
on november 4th
but it's true so it's richard on the
phone richard my friend for many many
years
and i said hey rich i don't mr president
sir how are you i said well
he's been calling me donny and don and
dj
and all richard are you okay everything
good
uh yes sir mr president sir you're doing
a great job and
i'd like to thank you good richard
richard listen up please you don't have
to call me mr president
i said so just call me donald it's okay
thank you donald i really appreciate it
and you hear the guy he can't breathe
you know he's having a hard time
breathing
he's very nervous and then at the end of
the phone he goes mr president again
thank you so much for the job you do
hangs up i said
how can you be friends with you know it
just doesn't work it's like
i've lost a lot of people this way there
is a lot
going on there psychologically that
would be
great fodder for a few years of
psychotherapy for donald trump really a
ton of it
but as a story to tell at a rally it is
bizarre
and odd and then this was maybe my
favorite moment of the entire rally
trump did the sir routine about melania
his wife so
the sir routine is when trump tells a
story
of someone talking to him he'll he'll
say and they came to me and they said
sir we can't do it or whatever
right this time he tells a story
in which melania refers to him as sir
outrageously bizarre happening that
thing would turn around like a pretzel
and i said oh it does move but they
never want to show
the crowds they never last night now i
went home and i tell you this i go home
all the time first lady
how'd you like the crowd sir i didn't
see it
i didn't see it melania said to trump
sir i didn't see the crowd
how strange is that is this confirmation
that trump's sir stories are lies
or is this an admission from trump that
his wife refers to him as sir
either way it's not exactly stable
genius
then trump went back to something he's
been talking about more and more lately
which is space exploration nasa nars
as he referred to it over the weekend
mars of course as you and i would know
it
and trump i guess because he's just
constantly thinking about golf
talked about nasa's great uh
fairways rather than runways take a look
on the moon in the united states will be
the first nation to land an astronaut on
mars
you know nasa was an absolute disaster
grass was growing through the
the fairways too they had fairways
that's about all they use with a fairway
and now we have something right through
the the runways
totally just utterly unintelligible
donald trump i don't know if people have
noticed this but we saw it there
trump does this unintentionally
hilarious thing
where most people when they read a
speech off of a prompter
the the idea is these are my words that
i'm reading this is my
speech trump reads the prompter almost
like he's reading a news article
and reacts to what's on the prompter
like it's news
and sometimes he actually seems sort of
like surprised by what's on the prompter
it's bizarre
then trump went into these uh
our our friend aaron rupar on twitter
called it gore
porn gore porn about ms13
using knives it this it just just makes
almost no sense at all
if you don't mind democrats we'll bring
them the hell out of our country we'll
get them out of here
some of them are so violent we have to
keep them we don't want to house them
for
50 years but if we let them go they come
back in as much as we watch you know
look if
they come back in we don't want it we
don't want them so we keep them here we
have no choice if the
left gains power they will abolish
republicans will always they're going to
abolish
republicans will always stand with these
incredible heroes of ice and
border patrol you have to see these ice
people they go into a den
of ms-13 they call them a den a nest
where you have these
guys that are vicious vicious gang
members
and they go in there they just start
swinging it's the craziest thing they
love it
now who wants that job do you want that
job look he's a tough guy
setting it you too you're tough guys you
don't want any part of it they're just
incredible and they love our country
they love our country and then people
say oh they're too rough
they're so rough you have no idea how
bad some of these gangs are what they do
they use knives because it's more
painful
they cut people up again the crowd is a
mix of people
some who will just clap at anything
trump there was a particular woman
behind trump
no matter what he said she would start
pumping her fists and and you know
cheering
anything he said but then there's
another half of the crowd
that has no idea what trump is talking
about they go almost silent during these
rallies
because it's all crazy trump then went
into the portion of the speech which
he's been doing lately
where he glorifies violence against
journalists
here he's talking about how funny it is
that a guy who was a reporter
was manhandled by law enforcement
grabbed them
they grabbed them they were grabbing
them left and right
sometimes they grab they grab one guy
i'm a reporter i'm a reporter
get out of here they threw him aside
like he was a little bag of popcorn
but no but i mean honestly when you
watch the crap that we've all had to
take so long when you see that it's
actually
you don't want to do that but when you
see it it's actually a beautiful sight
it's a beautiful sight trump says
reporters tossed around
by law enforcement you love to see it
says trump and again the crowd
some are cheering mindlessly but others
are sort of wondering like wait a second
we we toss around reporters now that
should i really be cheering for this
like there actually
are some people in the crowd who you can
see are a little tentative about what
trump is is talking about and then
continuing with the glorification of
violence against reporters
trump keeps mocking msnbc reporter ali
velshi
for getting hit with a rubber bullet or
tear gas in minneapolis
he refers to him as the cnn guy he's not
a cnn guy he's msnbc take a listen
go in we have the national guard and
remember that beautiful site
the street was a mess that idiot
reporter from cnn got hit on the knee
with a canister of tear gas right
and he went down i've been hit i've been
hit
he been hit the one with the shaved hair
shaved the hair maybe i'll do that one
day i'll give it up
so again he keeps telling the same story
the cnn guy the bald cnn guy he's
talking about msnbc's ali velshi
but we're laughing at media getting hit
that that does not seem american to me
it seems like the exact opposite
of everything i thought this country
was supposed to stand for and then trump
plays up
the joe biden dementia stuff and the joe
biden
is on drug stuff the gloves off
this guy doesn't have a clue he doesn't
know where the hell he is
and they'll give him a shot or something
i don't know he's going to get something
he'll be
you know because i watched him so badly
he performed so badly in the debates and
then
with bernie he was average not great but
he got through
and i said what the hell is he taking
and we'd like to ask him and i said that
we want a drug test we want a drug test
we'll both take
yeah trump just continues to act like
you know biden before the bernie debate
was like
sami sosa juicing to get more home runs
or something like that
very very strange and of course not
totally unreasonable to see this as
projection
maybe it's trump who's using uppers
to increase his performance and then the
last one that's just hilarious
um trump asks the crowd what gas
costs these days and someone yells out
that it costs
fifteen dollars and trump seems to
believe it
energy almost seven thousand dollars but
we have to include energy i mean how
much are you paying for your gasoline
you never saw two dollar gasoline you're
less right
it's less they go up it's less now it's
uh
it's a big difference what is it
nowadays come on tell me i haven't got
any guess
i haven't stopped recently at a gas
station i'm
15. okay because for a while it was uh
way under two imagine being so out of
touch
that you think gas might cost 15
per gallon like that would be weird for
the average american
maybe if you live in a city you don't
drive
you don't even go by a gas station or
when you do you don't look like
maybe somebody might not know is where
exactly is gas
trump is the president and he's talking
about gas prices
and someone yells out 15 and trump
thinks gas might be 15
a gallon i've had an electric car for a
while
i've not been to gas stations for a
while but i can be reasonably certain
that gas is like between a dollar eighty
and three seventy a gallon right if
somebody says gas is fifteen dollars a
gallon
it doesn't pass the sniff test trump is
the president and he says oh it's at
fifteen
no rally on today's schedule for donald
trump
as of right now he is scheduled to do a
press
conference um reminder september 29th
just six days away the first debate
between
joe biden and donald trump i will be
streaming it live
starting at 8 30 p.m in the east
5 30 p.m in the west on youtube
twitch and facebook and i do hope that
you will join me
uh you know we've been talking about the
possibility that on election day
donald trump will try to use federal
troops
to intimidate voters at polling places
and it turns out that trump may not even
have to
because his own supporters are showing
up at early voting sites
and already intimidating voters we're
seeing a
big advantage for democrats in terms of
absentee ballots and in terms of
early voting and the trumpists are
showing up
and doing what they can to intimidate
voters virginia
uh had its first week of early voting
groups of trump supporters
were showing up including in northern
virginia
blocking the path to the location
this was a disproportionately democratic
area of virginia
chanting four more years it actually led
to
county election officials having to
provide
escorts for voters to get past
the protesters groups of uh trump
supporters were
chanting four more years and doing all
sorts of other stuff we have video
this was captured by maryland
photographer anthony tillman
and you'll see the crowd carrying trump
signs flags chanting right outside the
building
making it difficult to get in and out
now remember
the legality of this is unclear
because electioneering at polling places
isn't allowed
what counts as being at the polling
place depends on the state in virginia
my understanding is that it's within 40
feet of the front doors
it certainly seems as though in this
video the protesters
are within 40 feet of the front doors
[Applause]
four more
[Music]
[Applause]
so as you can see trumpists creating a
blockade
chanting blocking the path in now there
are people who are saying including the
virginia republican party which i'll get
to
there are people saying this is an
intimidation
only the most triggered snowflake
could consider this intimidation anybody
can just walk by
guys this is not how elections are
supposed to happen
there is not supposed to be
electioneering at polling places if you
are
just to pick something if you're a 70
year old woman
showing up to vote for biden and you
have to weave your way through
a crowd of dozens of trumpists by the
front door
chanting blocking the path holding signs
screaming that is not how elections are
supposed to happen in the united states
there are election officials in fairfax
county virginia
and uh who are admitting that voters and
even some of the poll workers
felt intimidated by this crowd and again
they required
escorts to get people in and out of the
building
and again it's illegal in virginia you
can't be within 40 feet
of the precinct in virginia now
the virginia republican party just
mocked the entire thing
the new york times put out a story about
this and
the virginia republican party tweeted
the story with the message
quick someone called the wambulance
which is just
you know the height of maturity and
interestingly
some of the voters who were in line to
vote were asked
why are you standing in such a long line
to vote in person you could vote by mail
you're standing in line to vote early in
person
and voters said we don't trust the mail
take a look at this report from cnn
all right gentlemen i just want to step
out here so you can see just how far
back this line goes i mean it's about
two football fields here and keep in
mind this is a huge government building
in fairfax virginia the biggest county
here
and they're at capacity inside of the
building now they're trying to keep
people here
outside socially distant but as you can
see it is
difficult particularly given the fact
that this line is so enormous and once
they actually get
inside of the building there is still at
least an
hour and a half wait now we have talked
to several of these voters
about why it is that they chose to show
up early
many of them saying they knew it was
going to be a very
big election that it was critical that
there was going to be a lot of interest
they wanted to be one of the first
people to cast their ballot
but we also heard about mistrust of the
postal service take a listen to this
because i don't trust the mail right now
that's why and so that's why you decided
i gotta stand here all day i'm gonna
vote today so this gets me to the one
good thing
that i am seeing in terms of enthusiasm
it seems to be high i've been using this
phrase for a couple of months
people might be willing to crawl over
broken glass to vote
it seems people are willing to do it and
the death of ruth bader ginsburg
tragic and may lead to one of the most
conservative supreme courts in decades
but it seems to have increased
enthusiasm on the left
donations to democrats have been pouring
in
since the past passing of ruth bader
ginsburg and
if anything like this happens when you
are voting
i want to hear about it if you can
safely take video
take video and get it to me we will be
talking about the voter intimidation
that takes place
keep an eye out and let me know what you
see here is a voicemail
from a trumpist asking a question
that i think is worthy of discussion a
little bit uh take a listen to this
hey david uh i've called your show a few
times before
uh and left voicemail so kinda happy to
do it again
so anyways i was just curious about a
particular thing
uh as a jewish man yourself
uh how can you find yourself not
supporting donald trump
so i'd like to explain that first of all
as a voter of donald trump
i voted for him for an america first
foreign policy right
so my question well and he
has broadly pursued an agenda that's
been pro-israel
pro-zionist and my question to you is
that as a jew it seems like he's done a
lot for your
people my people um so i was just
curious about that
no trump has done nothing for my people
let this is this is a great opportunity
to uh to to explain uh american jews
are very liberal one of the most liberal
voting blocs in the country
and our priorities are left
priorities to different degrees you've
got center-left and more progressive
okay whatever
what donald trump has done with regard
to israel
is the same unproductive nonsense that
benjamin netanyahu has done
which is virtue signaling not so much
to jews but to these evangelical
christians
who have this messianic view
of what needs to happen in israel moving
the m if you're an american progressive
jew
and you see trump move the embassy from
tel aviv to jerusalem
that does nothing for me and in fact
it's an impediment to peace it's an
impediment to peace
so the framing is completely wrong trump
for
for my people trump has done nothing and
in fact
trump's presidency has normalized
the types of extremism that lead to
more out in the open anti-semitism so
the framing
could not be more wrong we've got a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about wait a second are democrats
looking at impeaching trump again
what is the point of that let's discuss
nine million americans
still haven't received their stimulus
checks and new york is among cities
losing financing by being designated
anarchist cities by trump's justice
department
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just
a reminder today's sponsor is blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire non-fiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video